what do you think are the strangest
maybe the most beautiful
or maybe even the most terrifying things
lurking out there in the cosmos
well of course we're still groping for
any detailed understanding of the remote
parts of the universe
but of course what we've learned in the
last few decades
is really two things first we've
understood that the universe had an
origin
about 13.8 billion years ago in a
so-called big bang a hot 10 states whose
very beginnings are still trousered in
mystery
and also we've learned more about the
extreme things in it
black holes neutron stars explosions of
various kinds
and one of the most potentially exciting
discoveries in the last 20 years mainly
the last 10 has been the realization
that most of the stars in the sky
are orbited by retinues of planets
just as the sun is orbited by the earth
and the other familiar planets and this
of course makes the night sky far more
interesting what you see up there aren't
just points of light but they're
planty systems and that raises the
question could there be life out there
and so that
is an exciting problem for the 21st
century so when you see all those lights
out there you immediately imagine all
the planetary worlds that are
around them and they potentially have
all kinds of different
lives
living organisms life forms or well in
history that we don't know at all we
know that these planets are there we
know that
they have masses and um orbits rather
like the planets of our solar system but
we don't know at all if there's any life
on any of them i mean it's entirely
logically possible that life is unique
to this earth doesn't exist anywhere on
the other hand uh it could be that the
origin of life is something which
happens
routinely given conditions like the
young earth in which case there could be
literally billions of places in our
galaxy where some sort of biosphere has
evolved and
settling
where the truth lies between those two
extremes
is a challenge for the coming decades
so certainly we're either lucky to be
here or very very very lucky to be here
i guess unless there is that's the
difference uh where do you fall
your own estimate your own guess on this
question are we alone in the universe do
you think
i think we're foolish to give any firm
estimate because we just don't know
and that's just a example of how
we are depending on greater observations
and also incidentally in the case of
life we've got to take account of the
fact that
as i always say to my scientific
colleagues biology is a much harder
subject than physics and most of the
universes we know about could be
understood by physics
but
we've got to remember that even the
smallest living organism
an insect is far more complicated with
layer on
complexity
than
the most complicated star or galaxy
you